this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app all the
babies use the cash app I'm telling you
it's probably why it's the number one
finance app in the App Store because it
is you know that and now the cash card
is more powerful than ever with the cash
absolutist feature cash boost download
the cash app get your free cash card and
select your boost save money when you
swipe on stuff like coffee
Chipotle Shake Shack and more download
the free cash app for iOS or Android or
is it episode cuz I said episode
normally I don't [ __ ] up that early but
I believe it's the where the word is
episode so yeah it is episode 73 or
episode 73 however you want to say
whether or not you're a [ __ ] but and
I'm this is it episode 73 we're getting
so close to a hundred and when we get to
a hundred who knows what we're gonna do
maybe we'll just have a [ __ ] big orgy
right here and a big audio orgy just a
bunch of dudes and chicks just doing all
the sorts of stuff you know
I am yesterday I didn't record because I
had a sore throat now that's definitely
submit to not record because you have a
sore throat but also just kind of wanted
to chill I didn't feel good and now
today of course I woke up in the Mustafi
as hell I was get stuffy after I get
sick but I wasn't even really sick you
know I'm not gonna let that I'm not
gonna let people I'm not gonna let the
sickness have me saying I'm sick I was
just chilling but I didn't have you know
what's weird is I was thinking about
this is you know you can like I don't
know my whole goal here on this well one
of them one of the goals is
- just be happy right and happiness
isn't having things happiness isn't
happiness is nothing but a feeling you
know and some days you wake up and
you're good to go for no reason some
days you wake up and you're just like
here we go [ __ ] for no reason
it's gonna be a bright bright sunshiny
day and that's playing right it's gonna
be a bright and you just [ __ ] are
killing it dude
and you'd walk down the street and for
no reason just feeling it dude right for
no [ __ ] reason and you're just having
a good day and then you go do your [ __ ]
right and then and then literally the
next day you wake up and it's [ __ ]
some what do you call it
song stained song some [ __ ] stained
song I woke up two days last week well I
woke up every day last week but one day
I woke up and I was just bummed as [ __ ]
dude
bummed is [ __ ] for no reason for no
reason dude have a good life good family
great friends money mmmm bank account
all the coffee I could want and I'm
squirting whenever I want to
but dude just was bummed all day and
then woke up and just all day it sucked
felt anxious for no reason couldn't
figure it out sometimes you figure it
out you know you're like oh I'm anxious
oh you know why I'm anxious because of
this I'm anxious because got girl
problems or i'ma check didn't clear or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and the next day
I woke up dude almost cried for no
reason just like some lonely
[ __ ] in the stained video
staring at a gaping uh like grand canyon
with water in it and [ __ ] CGI'd
seagulls for no reason
what's a stained song right whatever a
stained song is is this
nominal staring into a canyon with
singles that are CGI'd
[Music]
water and oasis silhouette Rihanna no
skies blue skies are gray dude
um I'm tired of everyone acting like
music is a bigger deal than it actually
[ __ ] is men you know what man we make
music such a big [ __ ] big deal and
people love it they say there's you know
what that's the soundtrack of my life uh
uh Oh eat a dick
it's not the soundtrack your life you
act an egotistical you're just a person
who goes to work and then goes home and
goes eats and goes to bed you don't have
a soundtrack to your life
no why you're not in a [ __ ] Zach
Braff movie keg you're not screaming
into an oasis for no reason dude you
don't have a soundtrack to your life you
just live life and you play the music
you want to play like I said in my last
special man I'm fly Manta flyer or man
I'm fire he's [ __ ] up folks he's
[ __ ] up left and right folks
man on flyer episode 73 man on flyer oh
[ __ ]
so so that's so that's um so anyway you
don't have a like I said on me like I
said I'm an on fire you get out of the
car you turn off the music the music
stops it doesn't keep going in your head
even if you got some [ __ ] going on
that's popping doesn't matter you get
out the car
and you're like oh [ __ ] yeah here we go
and then get out of turn and then you go
shopping and it's done and you just live
in regular life but my point is some
things are good and some days are bad
and I don't know why and that [ __ ]
bugs me man
it sucks is there anybody out there that
just wakes up every day happy if [ __ ]
anyone who tells you that they're like
that if they're not patch Adams is a
[ __ ] liar and they deserve to get
their [ __ ] [ __ ] they do they deserve
[ __ ] get straight you know what they
deserve dude I don't even make me I'm
telling you don't even make me you say
you're happy every [ __ ] day that's
right dude it's just it's just not it's
not it's not possible those patch out of
some other [ __ ] they need to take a
hike for real put on a bunch of put on a
vest with a bunch of pockets on it and
take a [ __ ] hike dude put on some
netting right hikers are always wearing
netting [ __ ] no matter what yeah
it's a nobody I got a net pocket so the
water comes out of the net and really
stop thinking so hard just take a
[ __ ] hike man I don't get camping I
won't ever get it no why we built all
these walls figured out how to make a
microwave you think I'm going back in
time Yeah right bro no way [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of here I'll tell you though we
make music a big deal and I don't think
we should I think we should footloose
dude when they're talking about dancing
and how no there should be no dance and
I get it I get it when that [ __ ] cop
flips up the Kevin Bacon's driver's
license and knew his [ __ ] chin
that was definitely ad lib you could
tell by the way Kevin Bacon reacted but
there's a thing where Kevin Bacon gets
out of the car and he's playing music
and the cop is like why you playing
music and he's like yeah is there some
law against and the cop goes like this
hey don't talk to me like that and flips
his ID up and into his mouth and and
Kevin Bacon the way he reacted you know
you know that it was was ad-lib and you
know the director was like hey cop
[ __ ] flip his ID up into his [ __ ]
Kevin Bacon face that's how you get real
[ __ ]
I don't like when they do that in movies
though when they do real [ __ ] like I
heard on that that Denzel Washington
like straight up punched somebody on
John Q dude if let me tell you some
anybody if any actor I don't give a [ __ ]
who they are actually punched me in a
rehearsal or some [ __ ]
oh my
dude I'm not even I'm not even gonna
punch him back I'm gonna [ __ ] their
[ __ ] that's what I'm gonna do okay
I go like this if it happens I get
that's my punch okay I go like this all
right yeah okay let's do the scene let's
get it down let's do it and then I
[ __ ] by the way murder the scene I
don't care if it's whatever it is I
murder the scene cuz I used the punch
cuz that's what he wanted me to do
anyway right okay and then I go and I
[ __ ] meet the guys girl on the
internet i DM the i DM the chick after
rehearsal and after shooting and then I
[ __ ] go and I meet up with her and we
make the [ __ ] out I don't even do it I
don't even have you know I don't even
have sex with her I just make out all
disrespectful with her and then she
wants it and I say no I can't because
I'm better than that I'm that good I'll
make out with your chick I have to [ __ ]
am I even talking about dude
this podcast is such [ __ ] but anyway
what I'm saying is we make music a big
deal here I also heard in that movie
that Nicole Kidman and Tom Cruise did it
that's that father
dude when when couples do movies that
[ __ ] is like like a ho but it's really
them it's like it's acting but it's
really them it's interesting it's got
another layer on it no just get two
[ __ ] people to do the thing not that
they were both they were both really big
stars far and away that's what it was
far and away weird where they played
Irish people and and there was one part
where Tom Cruise had a ball on his dick
and Nicole Kidman was supposed to open
up the ball and look at it and react
about his dick and there was a cloth
covering Tom Cruise's dick but Tom
Cruise was like hey man she's my wife
why don't I just use a [ __ ] why don't
I just you know have no cloth on my dick
and see we're gonna we'll get we'll get
her real reaction and the director was
like and that was the one they that was
the one we used classic cinema far and
away dude I love Tom Cruise I love
Nicole Kidman there isn't a movie I
would rather see less than far and away
so much Brown in it brown walls
hair brown vests skies Brown have
different colors and only brown and a
little bit of light blue and that's it
and maybe some pink every now and then
like the cheeks of the chicks and some
wallpaper and the most bitch-ass hats
and 47 boats for sure
oh and Sun and Sun time and Sun and
sunlight umbrellas deal with it
how's that if you're out in the [ __ ]
if you're out in the in the Sun deal
with it get a hat with a brim on it or
that's it no [ __ ] Sun sunglasses do
it I mean sunglasses are cool but uh
umbrellas if shit's not coming down out
of the sky [ __ ] put your umbrella was
that oh it's a [ __ ] one fires telling
me it's called a parasol and I'm no you
know what it's called an umbrella that's
what it's called parasol the only time
you can use a parasol is if you're
[ __ ] so Asian or super duper white in
the 1860s if you aren't either one of
those and also if you're Asian you have
this parasol you better have your white
gloves on - um anyway uh anyway I'm on
my app here and we're talking and I see
the comments coming in and you guys are
you guys are giving me good comments
somebody just wrote fart away okay cool
it's cool my thing my fanbase is really
smart um and some other person said the
movie with Tom Cruise and and what and
what and Nicole Kidman was far I was a
eyes wide shut which it is but also I
was talking about far and away um so
anyway we make music a big [ __ ] deal
is what I'm trying to get it and what I
my point is here his music is so much of
a big deal that I feel like
cuz I saw this everyone but cuz I gotta
talk about this cuz everyone's asking me
about this and it might must have been
because I him on my podcast but but
maybe not people like what do you feel
about xxx 10th St on by the way you name
change it just be extension alright now
I get you died and you got shot and
nobody really well not nobody but you
know people are like well whatever you
did you didn't deserve to get [ __ ]
killed that that was [ __ ] up by the
way 20 years old shot dead apparently he
was robbed and in and and and [ __ ]
out there just videoing it and putting
it online
I caught it by mistake I followed this
Instagram account and it was like and
all of a sudden I realized like I was
I'm scrolling I look at I'm looking at
this guy's dead body and I unfollowed
that page because like dude where are we
at the fact that we have come to the to
the point where we're videoing dead
bodies and posting them online like just
in the intrusion of not even privacy but
decency it's just so gross to me and
dude and it takes a lot to offend me man
but like posting it and doing it even
even if there is a dead body somewhere
to even get closer to it is weird as
[ __ ] to me let the police deal with it
these people were filming the police
filming the [ __ ] I didn't want to see
that [ __ ] and if if that were to happen
me I wouldn't want people to see it for
for freaking - for me it's just sad and
you know did the kid deserve to die now
obviously it takes a lot for somebody's
orders die now but my point is with the
music is like look he did make good
music you can't you know I liked his I
thought his music was really good it was
different it was soulful it made me feel
[ __ ] you know and all that what the guys
personal life was [ __ ] terrible I
mean he beat the [ __ ] out of a pregnant
lady
and a pregnant girl that he was you know
and this is all her her saying it in her
account but this accounts were so
specific and [ __ ] that it's hard to not
believe it but he ran into a lot of
trouble and in his life he was a
troubled troubled kid and so now ever
before he died everyone was like oh [ __ ]
this guy he doesn't deserve to be doing
concerts and [ __ ] he doesn't deserve to
be making art and this and that he's a
criminal
and now that he died everybody online is
touting him like the next [ __ ] Tupac
and it's like I know there were these
[ __ ] people out there that were just
like uh he's a terrible person and then
when he dies like I can't wait to fire
this tweet out alright P xxx 10,000 nah
man bury yourself dude get out of here
that's so annoying dude people who
weren't even fans of them are just like
oh man just heard his music what a shame
you don't even know what you're talking
about dude you don't know what you're
talking about
I mean look people
like other imagine imagine chris
hardwick died tomorrow they would just
be like yeah well he isn't it weird the
[ __ ] like I feel like music or
hip-hop it's hip-hop or whatever the
[ __ ] it is but it's like I was talking
to my buddy and we were talking about I
was talking my buddy about this and I
don't know I don't know if he'd want me
to even say his name I'm a podcast but
because of what I'm talking about is um
but whatever it is is a touchy subject
but he was like dude it's uh it's a it's
like it only it's like it matters more
when women give a [ __ ] about this stuff
like women are women obviously obviously
girls girls like hip-hop but like
athletes they get away with beating the
[ __ ] out of people and let's play in the
NFL but women don't give a [ __ ] about
sports generally I know obviously there
are some women that care about it but
like but like so so they get away with
it but the fact that some of the like
when you're in the zeitgeist or whatever
like you know if you're in the comedy
world or the acting world or the
production it's like so many women give
a [ __ ] about that so we demonize all
these guys that are in those in that
life because of the me to thing but not
these football players it's [ __ ]
insane dude there has to be a standard
there has to be a standard and that's it
and you know
like are we gonna believe women or not
that's the thing are we gonna [ __ ]
believe women or not because if we are
then how are you gonna act like oh you
know such a shame that xxx tense has
hyung got his [ __ ] [ __ ] got what was
coming to him well then you don't
believe the [ __ ] girl that said he
put a [ __ ] fork in her vagina okay
then you don't believe that girl
I mean who who this is a [ __ ] touchy
thing to talk about but like this kid
who made great art was a piece of [ __ ]
that's it whether he's dead or alive
that's what it was okay
yeah did you know he didn't deserve to
die I think did he deserve to thrive off
of his career not if all that shit's
true with that girl saying and if we're
gonna believe women you got to go to
[ __ ] jail for that but he wasn't
gonna go to jail there's no [ __ ] way
there's no way he was gonna go to jail
dude there's no way it's weird dude it's
weird what people pretend to care about
and then let slide it's so [ __ ] weird
how could you let that slide
maybe you guys
themselves when they act like cuz
there's creeps out there that are
feminists to man and they just use that
I mean I think most of the guys
feminists are probably like that they
use that because they're like oh I can
hide behind this and everyone will think
I'm a good guy but really you go out and
you have a [ __ ] abusive relationship
with a girl just that people hate fake
[ __ ] and they they can't wait to get you
on some [ __ ]
that's why politicians fall so [ __ ]
easy you know that's it's it's it's like
if yours it's almost like if you're a
scumbag you're impenetrable if you're a
known scumbag what was it uh I don't
know anyway let's talk about something
lighter I guess Deardon
anyway I you know people are like rest
in peace or whatever but you're just
gonna people say rest in peace - do you
rest in peace are you just dead
I guess it's peace if you're not doing
anything I the culture that we live in
where people are just trying to expose
everyone is hilarious and then and then
and then how about this when we when
when I just found out who that little
Tay was that little asian girl who's
like I got money I'm 9 I got I got all
these cars and houses her mom apparently
her mom was a realtor and just videoing
her in different houses that she was
trying to sell and they found her like
footage of little tea not doing that
stuff and everyone was like oh see we
told you it was all an act
hey dude if you thought who looks at
this little taste [ __ ] and is like oh I
got to figure out if that's an act or
not what do you what are you what are
you talking about she's 9 it's an act
she's being coached obviously how do you
fall for some stupid [ __ ] like that
lillte is an act because she's 9 and no
9 year olds have a bunch of different
houses and stacks and racks and racks
and stacks of money dude she's not
but she's [ __ ] nine years old how do
you just start out with nut with money
she doesn't have a job she makes no
money stop people like Lula exposed know
she wasn't exposed you know who's
exposed you cuz you're [ __ ] idiot and
an ignoramus for believing the fact that
she was really doing that [ __ ]
I'm little Tay I got more money than you
you ain't [ __ ] I got cars no you don't
know you don't know you don't know
you're not you're not even little tag
your name's [ __ ] Jen or some [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] can people be so stupid to be
like oh I gotta click on this I knew she
was fake see look at that eyes she's
fake I knew it
look at her crack that's not her
character no [ __ ] she wasn't exposed you
were you were exposed for being a
[ __ ] dumbass [ __ ] that's what
you were IIIi just little Tay lil why is
everybody lil little baby I just heard a
song from Drake and Lil baby I don't
know if it's new or not but lil baby you
don't have to be little baby you can
just be baby you know why a baby is
already a lil as I call yourself [ __ ]
little monopoly piece yo what up is
little monopoly piece here we pass and
go collected $200 [ __ ]
when we do pass go 47 times cuz we
making this money little monopoly piece
a hey that's what I won't be if my right
I was a rapper
well monopoly piece but yeah you can't
expose something that's that's like
exposing lillte for being not who she
said she was is like exposing me as
being as having a [ __ ] penis I got
one got hair on my face man you unzipped
my pants was a penis not everyone's
gonna be like oh I [ __ ] told you he
was dude told you he had feet look he
took his shoes
there they are 10 to 10 toes and all so
weird dude we just can't if you're gonna
demonize you know Hardwick you got a
demon eyes
xxx dentition as well I'm not taking
away from the guys music look you know I
mean and also I mean look at midnight
was a [ __ ] fun show to do
yeah it's like that Roseanne thing they
took it down and [ __ ] it's like
everyone's out of work it's a publican
weird weird weird [ __ ] time man this
internet it's just [ __ ] making
everything quote unquote
right on the liberal side but it's like
also your [ __ ] crybabies as well so
we're going we're letting a pendulum
swing way too far on one way anyway I'm
gonna read these ads quip when you walk
down the toothbrush aisle at the store
it doesn't take too long to realize
there are lots of options and many of
them are gimmicks the truth is you
really just need something that guides
the simple habits most of us get wrong
when brushing our teeth and quip knows
that that right
for starters quip is an electric
toothbrush that's it's at a fraction of
the cost of the bulkier brushes while
still packing just your mind just the
right amount of vibrations to help clean
your teeth it's got a built-in timer
that helps you switch sides so you're
doing it for long enough and it's it's
it it it's two minutes each side and
it's the dentist recommend you clean
here's the deal quips built-in timer
helps you clean for the dentist
recommended two minutes with guiding
pulses that remind you when to switch
sides that's the way to say it and
everyone loves quip I was on Oprah's o
list named one of Times best inventions
and is the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
Dental Association
so you got bad teeth you gotta get this
and if you got good teeth you got to get
a two to keep them good clip starts at
just $25 and if you go to get clip comm
/ Congrats right now you'll get your
first refill pack free with a clip
electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get clip comm / Congrats spell GE tqu IP
comm / Congrats square cash hi guys if
you haven't heard we are Sui are
switching to the cash app right now you
know it's the number one ranked app in
finance and lets you do the most with
your money whether you want to pay
people back buy and sell Bitcoin deposit
your paycheck right into the app or
order a free custom cash card to spend
everywhere you like and now the cash
card is more powerful than ever with
cash apps latest feature cash boost the
cash cards boost program lets you get
instant discounts every time you swipe
your card right now you can get a dollar
off every purchase you make at coffee
shops across the country when you pay
with your cash card um it's available
you get 15% off at Chipotle 50% off at
Shake Shack and more they got a new
boost for the cash card constantly so
follow at Cash app on Instagram and
Twitter to find out where the boosts our
necks there's also a cash card it's a
black debit card that you can design
yourself we have one and a lot of people
tweet me what their designs are and it's
very cool a lot of people put on you
know the design for no kuda or whatever
you can make it yourself the way you
want to do it and of course when you
download the cash app and enter rewards
codes Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now now I'm not gonna be a faker
I'm sweating my [ __ ] balls off and
that's what's happening I got I got em
sweat dripping down my burly hairy chest
onto my midsection now if I have my
shirt off which is camouflage and you
can see on the video podcast if I had my
shirt off
I'd be naturally sexy as [ __ ] because
all of those beads of sweat are [ __ ]
cascading down from my burly tit like
chest and [ __ ]
bumping over like it's a like it's a
black diamond ski course on my [ __ ]
eight-pack that's what's happening hands
down now why is it so sexy
besides that say not a fan of the
[ __ ] tinted chest I got and my
[ __ ] mogul black diamond [ __ ] a
ski course okay where is it all going
it's [ __ ] running plush into my wiry
pubes now that's beautiful to have with
your sweating out say what you want and
I don't mean to make the housewives go
crazy but I've got my [ __ ] burly
chest producing beautiful beautiful
beads of sweat cascading we have for a
limited time beautiful beads of sweat
bubbling up on at it like chest through
the hair running down over a black
diamond white powdered advanced mogul
ski course for a limited time until it
runs plush into wiry
ill trimmed pubes making them wet now
we're offering you these beads of sweat
not we're not gonna offer them from now
we're not gonna offer them for $200 we
are not going to offer these beautiful
sweat filled beads shiny sweat failed
beads limited edition okay
skating shiny beads we are not offering
them for $120
we are not let me tell you what we're
not offering these shiny plush beads
that cascade down into wiry pubes for we
are not offering them for $80 we are not
offering them for $70
can we go we're gonna go you know what
there to help me not to go lower I'm go
lower
we are not ordering look these beat I'm
having lift we've got a few left we are
not offering these beautiful human sweat
filled beads they always end on a sharp
note sweat filled beads to say sweat
filled beads but they don't do that we
are beautiful sweat filled
[Music]
for $20 we're not we're not could we
give them we're not we are offering them
right now 12 a dozen limited-edition
shiny sweat filled human beads running
over an advanced Dimond cocaine white
beige 8 pack abdomen ski course triple
diamond as they run plush into
[Music]
electrical looking wiry tough pubic
hairs for six dollars called now we've
got to do even have any left we have
some left but they're going let's move
on to the next thing we're serving tanks
we've
taints off of people from northern
Canada and we're selling them now these
paints are not [ __ ] did on one day I
want to work for one of those guys and
then and then I want the girl to be like
the girl that's I want is what I want I
want the girl to be [ __ ] doing it
with the Jew it's nice look at this
little ceramic dolphin we got a
beautiful ceramic dolphin we're selling
these dolphins a beautiful handmade
handcrafted I want to go like this I
want to go over there I want to walk
over there I'm gonna get real sexist on
her I'm gonna grab the [ __ ] dominant
dolphin with the hand and brush her with
like my [ __ ] shoulder like kind of
shoulder check her check her and I just
want to be like give me that give me
this [ __ ] and then I want to be like
hey we got these [ __ ] dolphins you
want to buy a [ __ ] dolphin or what
that's it that's it I don't need to
describe you could see him you want the
[ __ ] dolphin or not if you're in the
market for a ceramic dolphin get the
[ __ ] ceramic dolphin if you don't I
swear to God do it if I did that [ __ ] I
think we'd get a new like why was taking
this today if Iran if Iran me Chris
D'Elia me if Iran movies that are coming
out if Iran their twitters I could get
them way more V I bet I could get more
people in seats like take the gaudy
movie that movie if Iran the gaudy movie
that's coming out this weekend right if
Iran that Twitter account that's a wrap
I swear to god that movie will make way
more money if Iran the Twitter account
just based on that [ __ ] PR alone hey
go [ __ ] people be like I can't wait to
see this guy I'm thinking about going to
see it I'd right back and retweet and go
[ __ ] yourself we don't need you
[ __ ] I'm just eating some
[ __ ] provolone a salami people will
be like oh [ __ ] what is this a we in the
[ __ ] mafia I would just tweet [ __ ]
like that so disrespectful a we in the
[ __ ] Mafia
go [ __ ] yourself I'm gonna put too
back your [ __ ] head if somebody says
yeah I didn't really like Gaudi I really
well I'm putting two in the back of the
[ __ ] your head I'm in the [ __ ]
back of your head and then and then then
then and then people will go together
oh she's a [ __ ] Gotti Twitter we
gotta go see that movie what are they
[ __ ] insane
we have gaudy tickets beautiful ticketed
movie yeah dude I need to [ __ ] have a
now that it's summer it's so hot in
these studios I need to have a [ __ ]
towel like I'm a black comic or some
[ __ ] oh we got them terrycloth uh yeah
I'm like a [ __ ] I'm like Cedric the
Entertainer I don't know if he does that
maybe it's just racist but I know Leslie
Jones does it so there you go um anyway
[ __ ] we can't we can't uh you can't when
my oh yeah there you go my buddy I was
talking about child abuse with my buddy
and how wrong it is and it is you should
never hit your child I think by the way
we got these terrycloth are they still
on the website or no yeah
these may be sold out but yeah I'm
weapon my [ __ ] midsection with it
keepin it oh it's so sexy but I got to
keep it not saying I got to keep it dry
I'm sorry guys I got to keep it dry I
know when this gets dry so do your in
between your legs but what was I saying
oh yeah here's the child abuse you got
to do you don't hit kids never you never
hit kids and here's the other thing too
you don't even hit if you're you gotta
wait to your kids aid team to do
anything period any kind of emotional
kind of abuse or punching abuse or
whatever I don't think that moved you
want to check that I hit the pillow may
have [ __ ] knocked a but here's what
you do if you're a guy uh if I'm a guy
if I'm gonna die no I don't have kids
okay and people are always like you sure
yeah I'm sure dude that joke has played
the [ __ ] out all right I always wrap it
up and still pull out but
here's what you do here's how here's the
only child abuse that's okay and it's
all it gotta be after 18 anyway they got
to be a grown adult can't do this [ __ ]
when they're younger than that so it's
not really child abuse it's more like
adult abuse but it's still your son and
you're in your blood if I had a kid that
ever betrayed me and I'm say I'm 60 well
I guess ya know 60 and my kids 22 like
if I had a kid this year doing maths
quick in my head
genius [ __ ] straight up straight up
smart with math dude I'm the worst at
math actually but um anyway if my kid
ever lis ever like severely betray me I
make it my point seriously to have sex
with his girlfriend that's it I don't
care what who she is I don't care what
the [ __ ] they want that's what's up I
want and diner though like I get real I
get real care I put on my carriage I use
my eye I'm gray now too cuz I'm sixty
but I get real good with it man and I
and I start treating right you know and
I do the French I do the thing that I
hate that guys do I do the thing about
how guys are like guys like I hate the
guy that like tries to befriend the girl
to get laid like don't do that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass you you try to
get laid start to try and get laid some
jump baby hey what's up first question
yes you got a boyfriend no let's [ __ ]
get it going you don't [ __ ] know well
let's get a coffee see where things go
mmm you know if you're attracted to her
or not okay if you don't [ __ ]
straight-up turn round her and ran ran
ran ran round the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
I hate those [ __ ] beta as
[ __ ] well we're just friends I don't
know if I'd want to ruin the
relationship and actually kiss her faith
room just drove over yeah okay
just drove over you beep-beep whoops
reversed it over your [ __ ] face
reverse did some Mexican
hey reversed it over his face um yeah
dude but like dude one fires dying right
now but that's the thing dude
you don't be a [ __ ] band you come
with the real [ __ ] do it hey what's up
what we doing here
hey the [ __ ] are we doing here girls
want that guy they want that guy that's
like the Punisher worries like who's the
guy that what's his name that played the
Punisher
John what is it no not that one [ __ ]
Thomas Jane he says the new one
what's his [ __ ] name I know the guy
[ __ ] terrible I don't know not Ben
Barnes Ben Barnes is my legit friend
just [ __ ] click it one fire MDB Jon
Bernthal girls want a guy that just like
that Hey
and you're like what's going on ah
something else is going on I don't know
that's either guy from the beginning of
The Walking Dead by the way that's that
it's either Jon Bernthal or the other
guy they want that guy that's got like a
[ __ ] something going on hey hey
what's going on are you okay yeah I mean
no everything's good now but like a scar
on his face or like you know a ratted up
jean jacket with like [ __ ] maybe some
blood or paint on it um I mean look how
many guys have played The Punisher dude
Norman Norman Reedus played it in Iron
Man anyway what was I talking about
was even talking about dating in the oh
yeah that's how I guess yeah I can't
stand about guys [ __ ] being that but
that's what the girls want yeah that's
what I'm saying if you're coming at a
girl and you're trying to get you know
meet her and date her and court her or
how are you gonna
you know you got to come you got to come
correct dude you don't blindside the
girl by well you don't lie to yourself
either
you don't blindside the girl by saying
well I but this is what I actually mom
let's get alone and get on the couch bye
dad hey oh you want to make me squirt no
well I'm squirting Oh God hmm maybe no
and don't lie to yourself either dude
you know what you want [ __ ] figure
out what you want before by the way
figure out what you want before you even
talk to anybody how about that let alone
a chick don't be pretending like you
wanna be friends with this chick when
you don't wanna be friends with this
chick you want more than that
alright night I'm not saying you could
be friends with someone that you ain't
[ __ ] but you can you can be friends
with someone you [ __ ] but I'm just
saying you want more than that so don't
come with the girl and then d'lai to
your sava well friends I wouldn't want
to ruin the relationship oh really you
want to squirt okay um so the bottom
line is that's what the girl that's what
girls want even if they say they don't I
want a nice guy I'm tired of these jerks
really no you're not you know why
because you're saying that if you
weren't saying that then you would just
be doing it people who talk about [ __ ]
don't get [ __ ] done I've been saying I
wanted to start a clothing line for
years see I don't have one because I
don't want to do it alright so that's
the thing so I'm not doing that if my
son ever betrays me and he's 22 23 24
and I'm 65 I'm pulling out all the stops
dude I mean I'm talking about um you
know let's just I'm doing serious
betrayal [ __ ] let's talk about let's
talk about what's going on with my son
you know this end out with the chick
okay cool yeah well meet for coffee
whatever yeah there's an that we talk
and I get in on the eye
get in down low I'm just friendship
before you know it I'm turning on the
[ __ ] charm I'm doing that I'm slowly
sliding into that [ __ ] like 90s Hugh
Grant style type like oh excuse me but
you're comfy I don't know if you want
one layer or not but power here it is
anyway if you don't I'll drink to and
you're like ah he's dead cute and quirky
I'll drink three if I have to I'll pull
one on my head yeah I'll do it for
children if it helps right dude that
before Hugh Grant got busted you know
[ __ ] that guy or whatever it was when
he was with Elizabeth Hurley the hottest
girl of all time in the 90s before that
I'm that Hugh Grant I I slowly slide
into that Hugh Grant territory that's
what I do and then when she starts when
I noticed she looks at me a little bit
differently when we're at a [ __ ] walk
in the park or were at the observatory
and our I'm going to Sea World dude I'm
going everywhere you betray me if I made
you and you betray me all bets are off
that's it go to lunch we're out and I
and I get in and when I see her look at
me in that in that different way with
that Glen where it's like huh huh you
know the chick just like yeah he's my
friend but huh I feel warm around him
though I feel protected I feel protected
and that is when I slowly slide into the
[ __ ] The Punisher [ __ ] man I'm like
yeah well I haven't told you everything
about my past really what I don't want
to talk about it huh okay well not only
to protect me but it's a and interesting
and I keep fit too I start if I'm not
working out by then I work out I start
working out because I need to have fit
shredded
I need a [ __ ] Black Diamond course on
my stomach dude and I need some [ __ ]
some titted chests and she and then one
day we're at the beach she sees me take
my shirt off
over-over dude and then that's when you
know later that night
[Music]
you shouldn't have [ __ ] with me person
I made you shouldn'ta [ __ ] with me son
and then we go into an end at dude and
then I'm saying that's it dude she's
mine now North Carolina your girls and
my your girl is mine and you're good I
made you and you disrespected me and now
should it take you and took your girl
dude you shouldn't have [ __ ] with me
dude and then guess what I take her on a
world tour and we got a new song for you
and we're [ __ ] everywhere near
explosions we're [ __ ] near moat on
motorcycles where she I'm sure by the
way what's the [ __ ] that's then
that's a number that's such a movie
trailer song
[Music]
different cuts of [ __ ] and then
shooting and then on a motorcycle and
then jumping off of a mountain with a
parrot with a [ __ ] parachute and then
she [ __ ] while shooting have you ever
seen that Nicolas Cage movie where they
actually do that with it with their
[ __ ] and then he [ __ ] bends over
and he shoots people and she's holding
the girl and he's rolling around
shooting bad guys hey how did you make
it it's like one of those 47 Nicolas
Cage movies that came out in one year
now it's free [ __ ] you can make that
movie but hey that's it
unbelievable it was unbelievable how
they did that it's not that movie I
think yeah it's Drive Angry that's what
it is
I think it's Drive angry because I think
that girls in it um do I could never
remember people's names when I'm
shooting when I'm doing this podcast
Amber Heard yep he [ __ ] yep he's
having yep there it is he's having sex
with and he's got and he's got
sunglasses on and also he's smoking a
cigar hey dude this guy just loves
stimulation
oh he's not having sex with Amber Heard
it's a different girl and she's naked
tits are all out and other guys got an
axe and the guy has an action throws the
axe at Nicolas Cage and he oh and he
shoots him from behind his back hey
wouldn't happen so wouldn't happen
shoots the guy and he flies out of the
window would so wouldn't happen well
none of it would I love movies like that
dude [ __ ] it [ __ ] when people watch
these movies and they're like oh it's so
fake a bro no [ __ ]
that's the whole point that's like
rubbin peanut butter all over your face
and saying tastes like peanut butter
what the [ __ ] hit the [ __ ] Oh what did
he shoot that into his head I shot the
[ __ ] machete but hey man open your
mouth
lose the cigar he's got unfuckin like
our nets or our nays whatever you call
them those aren't it me or those
sunglasses that were this [ __ ] in the
90s rnase I had some green ones I was
walking around thought it wasn't working
the [ __ ] RNAi arnett who gives a [ __ ]
our net I think they probably just
called our net and people thought they
were cool of saying are naked like I bet
it's fun wow dude I love I love it dude
I need to fight if you by the way if you
were having sex and this song came on
the iPod I mean what would you
like what what would you what would you
it would be funny I would be laughing so
hard I'd be laughing I'd be laughing and
coming I'd be laughing and coming it's
better than coming anyway that's what I
would do I would do that I would want to
dine this girl then I put the Hugh Grant
on her then I put the [ __ ] Punisher
on her and then I'll go back and I'd
[ __ ] spend the weekend with her and
make some love with her and I do some
serious straight some serious straight
[ __ ] til I bet I do my doom I do love
making I'd kiss her but I'd also do the
like that stuff where I grab her hair
like just the way she wants it and stuff
like that and then I roll on over to my
son's house there's a professional human
being at this point and I'd [ __ ] you
know what dude yeah absolutely shouldn't
have done what you did to me and guess
what and I got my I got my phone up and
I got the under I'm the version of the
John Cusack thing with the stereo
standing on top of his car but I'm on
top of my car and I'm holding my phone
and I'm playing and I'm doing it like
this and I'm saying hey son you
shouldn't have [ __ ] with me guess what
I did I wanted to dine your girl and I
made love to her and then I had sex with
and then I [ __ ] her I made love and
then I [ __ ] her
I made you don't [ __ ] with me man I can
be very charismatic and I can turn from
Hugh Grant to The Punisher in the blink
of an eye I could turn from regular
friend guy to Hugh Grant into blink of
an eye and then Hugh Grant's to The
Punisher in one blink of a [ __ ] eye
that's three blinks [ __ ]
that's three blinks and your girl is
mine dude three [ __ ] blinks I made
you dude I need to make kids so I can do
this kind of [ __ ] man I swear I need to
make kids so I can put some of this [ __ ]
into effect dude [ __ ] the most
interesting man in the world that shit's
mmm bro you know what also I want to
fight that guy I want to fight the actor
who does that just for just for some PR
I
yeah that's the new dye
called that's the new Game of Thrones
here man all right let's do some Twitter
questions huh ma but we do some some
Twitter questions let's get some of
these Twitter questions going hey Apple
I don't always want to update everything
okay so how about this when they say
trying an hour try tonight remind me
tomorrow now just get out of here
yeah all right try tonight then cool see
ya you don't need to [ __ ] always be
oh well you heard that I just had
indigestion cool this is a good question
Gabe etemon or gay beat men do you ever
wonder what it would be like if you had
a sister you know what
and not really but every now and then I
have you're an elder by the way so we
take your question very seriously um
sometimes I I have wondered what it
would be like if I had just I don't know
I guess would be crazy there how's that
for some [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know what
it's like to have a sister I don't know
what it's like the only girl that I have
in my family is my mommy mmm I am but
that's you know I'm talking about
immediate um pretty crazy I suppose I'd
want to I suppose I'd be overprotective
maybe I don't know I don't know well my
brother would be with my sister too if I
had one
you know you stumped me elder maybe
that's why you're an elder if I had a
sister
yeah how about this when people say this
I'd be crazy town I'll [ __ ] wipe my
ass wipe wipe my ass with your nose um
here we go
Pierluigi Farrah not oh hey dude got a
quick question for you could you be more
Italian Piero PLO Aegean arthur
Pierluigi if Arenado ask me a question
what are your thoughts on people who say
beep beep
instead of excuse me when trying to get
by people anybody anybody like that you
deserve to get in them because there are
they're only cars go beep people ok
oh you know you should do for people who
do that grant start grabbing at them and
then when they're like well hey what are
you doing get off of me you're like oh
oh dude I'm so sorry man I thought you
were a [ __ ] motor vehicle and I was
trying to get inside you don't say beep
beep say excuse me and then I walk away
with my ice cream or wherever I was all
pissed off looking all pissed off
what do you man theny worthy from
Anthony worthy Anthony worthy worthy
underscore Anthony what do you imagine
this story arc my beef of the inevitable
future production of a Netflix
docu-series of the congratulations call
well I'll tell you it starts with my son
me [ __ ] up you know cuz he back step
back stab me well this guy had sex with
his son's girlfriend what the [ __ ] who
is this guy and then it goes back and it
has footage that's all grainy even
though footage is in grainy anymore cuz
is 2018 we make it grainy to make it
look more interesting and it shows me
doing my podcast in the beginning of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then how he and then he
implemented video and like like Kenneth
Branagh is doing the over there and then
I entered an included video you know and
and and and and and then it shows me
doing the video and then it shows me how
it shows and people are like hey and
then we play it up like we get about
actors to play this but they're like
yeah we're in the cult we live by the
code you know and and then it shows a
bunch of that and then shows us at the
log cabin of course eventually and we're
all [ __ ] and sucking and sharing
ideas and drinking nice water out and
sometimes we are out on the grass and
just chilling out Indian style and we
all have white robes on and wearing
linen like we're in a [ __ ] Puff Daddy
party and and then it ends with my
eventual you know demise I guess and
then the last interview is my son and
he's like you know I know he I know if
he says very seriously and these are the
words he says I know he [ __ ] my [ __ ]
but you know he was just he was an
artist in life and the world was just it
was his stage and
I guess I I don't know what else to say
that was my father
then the credits roll you can buy the
soundtrack and this is the soundtrack
[Music]
get all these songs sanchow costs four
hundred thousand million dollars to get
but that's the soundtrack I'm sweating
like a [ __ ] huh hey pretty cool
dude pretty cool I'm sweating like
[ __ ]
let me read off these things for you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] guys and chicks
square K square cash check out the new
boost rewards program get the cash app
enter rewards code congrats get $5 and
give times up give $5 - times up the
organization there it's a good organ
organization that we stand behind here
congratulations get it for iOS get it
for iOS or Android now look I'm gonna
name some of these dates here coming up
I followed the leader tour biomat buy
tickets at Crystal accom Ottawa Ontario
London Ontario Buffalo New York
Burlington Vermont Philadelphia
Washington New York Montclair Portland
Snoqualmie Washington Vancouver Miami
West Palm Beach Jacksonville Atlanta Los
Angeles San Francisco Boston Fresno
Bakersfield Austin San Antonio Tulsa
this weekend Tulsa this weekend Midwest
City this weekend Dallas Portland Maine
Hampton Beach Mashantucket change it
houston Wichita Kansas Kansas for some
reason Kansas City Missouri Lincoln
Nebraska for some reason Reno Nevada and
Las Vegas Nevada and that's what we're
coming that's where we are coming dude
subscribe to the YouTube channel
download the Chris D'Elia app for iOS or
Android you get to see that this podcast
before anyone else live and comment on
it and I see your comments and we talk
about them sometimes so subscribe
this also helps subscribe rate and
review the show tweetmeme by using the
handle at congrats pod or by using the
hashtag congratulations pod and the
video episodes go up Tuesday's or
Wednesdays watch man on fire and are
incorrigible at listen man you don't
have to ask me where's the podcast
where's the podcast hey where is it
sometimes I do it on Tuesday I have
always said that if you're asking
where's the podcast you're not a true
baby because you don't listen to the
cult leader this is a cult and I'm the
cult guy I'm the guy that tells you
stuff I don't say leader you know it's
for you to design but it's like this is
a cult listen to what I say the podcast
comes up Monday or Tuesday so don't
tweet me Tuesday morning where's the
podcast guess what it's coming don't
make me [ __ ] clap back to you I want
to say I love you guys but you know what
I don't know so many of you and you can
only love somebody if you know them
deeply but thank you for listening and
you guys are [ __ ] what you guys are
Mikey
dude thanks for listening to [ __ ]
episode 73 man on flyer
[Music]